que vous voudriez vous gardiez donner
cette femme trie ses déchets pour la
première fois ce geste est banal
aujourd'hui
mais en 1974 c'était une expérience
unique et inédite lancée par la ville de
la rochelle
[Musique]
derrière cette initiative
le conseiller municipal andré dubosc et
un industriel rochelais michel tissot
qui venait de déposer un brevet pour
recycler le père et c'est pour eux le
tri sélectif avait deux objectifs
économiques et écologiques
il faut savoir que la france bénéficiera
c'est toutes les villes comme la
rochelle se lancer dans une opération
analogue inverserait sa balance
commerciale d'achat du papier
actuellement le papier coûte à la france
en devises ce que lui rapporte
l'industrie automobile dans les annexes
porte à sion je pense qu'en plus nous
apportons un début de solution aux
problèmes écologiques aux problèmes de
pollution qui est actuellement est
considéré par tout le monde comme très
important très vite les rochelais adopte
le geste du tri pour notre côté aussi
vos bouteilles en plastique et réussir
deux manches et vous mes cartons et
mercier qu'est ce que vous pensez de
cette opération c'est utile et c'est
très bien
cette expérience un retentissement au
niveau national la ville du havre limite
la même année et le ministre de la
qualité de vie prend l'initiative en
exemple je ne sais pas si vous avez lu
l'article concernant la rochelle il ya
un papier concernant la récupération des
ordures ménagères caté mise au point par
monsieur le maire de la rochelle pour
ses récupérations de carton et de papier
c'est une excellente initiative chaque
maire doit le faire mais l'expérience
trop coûteuse va s'arrêter au bout de
trois ans il faudra attendre une loi en
vingt ans plus tard pour que toutes les
villes soit obligé de mettre en place le
tri sélectif afin de recycler et
valoriser les déchets
[Musique]